yeah no one cares no one cares
at all imagine if you will that you
can't swim
and i've chucked you in the deep end and
all you're doing
is flapping your arms trying to get
breath now imagine 7.5 billion people
doing that metaphorically every single
day your wants and needs are your wants
and needs
everybody else has got so much [ __ ] in
their life that even if you were a
passing for
you'll be quickly forgotten with the
amount of problems that that person has
to solve each day so if you're
hindering yourself based on the things
that other people who aren't even
considering you are thinking then you're
doing yourself a disservice
because no one cares
i'm joined by jamie alton jamie welcome
to the show
chris thanks for having me on pleasure
for you to join us today
talk to me about what you've been doing
what's your day got in store for you
um today well at the moment we're just
building our new offices so we're kind
of um
to and from there um i've got a lot of
client work doing so i run two
memberships uh
kind of a b to i say b to b so helping
uh
finch professionals scale and grow their
business and the b2c side helping people
get healthier happier fitter and
stronger so
you know spinning those two plates is is
um
full-time job uh and obviously i have no
clue about building stuff
you know i go into the builders and
they're talking about i have no idea and
i just have to say to them look i do
push-ups for a living you need to like
you need to get like a whiteboard and
draw it out in crayons for me so
they they're getting there but you know
how i've made it this far with stuff
like that i don't know
there's got to be a point in every man's
life where he becomes his dad
in terms of capability for diy i haven't
crossed that threshold yet yeah
that will never happen unfortunately i
still to this day
at 35 years of age if i need a pitcher
um put up
uh my dad will get the phone call i i
have attempted and this office looks
really nice
but it's just an office of lies because
behind every single frame
is holes like and and
really deep bits of plaster that's been
crisped off the wall
i literally have yet to successfully put
up a picture
because i only have two tools chris if
it doesn't go in with a allen key or
hammer
then that's it and the dad gets the
phone call
yeah i i wish that i could say i wasn't
outsourcing everything
manly to my dad as well i don't feel
emasculated by that i think that we are
the
savant 21st century man
yeah i mean my ironing game's on point
but that's what seven years in the army
does so yeah
you kind of forced to those kind of
things so so my wife gets me through all
the ironing
um and to be honest we
we share like she she does the lawn now
a lot of guys would think that mowing
the lawn is a very
masculine thing to do and and like we
said you said with this
one thing i disagree
we have we have like a a weird exchange
of things
even cooking food i cook the steaks okay
she does the roast potatoes you know we
all have our roles with certain things
and it's just based on the skills that
we have
no not nothing to do with gender at all
it's due to who's better at that job
and do it and i i for some reason i've
never enjoyed mine the law that is a
very egalitarian household
right there quality of access to the to
the ironing board equality of access to
the mower outside
yeah well there you go i mean we just
find the best person for the job
and if we both dislike it outsource what
exactly that's it
what a wonderful way that you could just
scale a family forward now
yeah well we're training we our
daughter's six coming on seven and she's
like
she's she's getting there with a few
things she actually enjoys cleaning
which has got big smile on my face
yeah that's it so what you need to do is
develop your child into
the weakness in both yours and your
misses
at the moment at the moment bribery's
working
um trolls world tour stickers
okay the only thing the only thing is
that atp a pack
of eight i think it is and thing is is
you know these sticker books
they sound like a good idea at first but
you've got probably about 450 quids
worth of stickers in there
and it's even worse when you get to the
end because you're buying
all of these packets of stickers and
she's already got them trying to get the
one that you need
have you have you pro-rotted out what
that comes out to an hourly rate because
my business partner who loves a
spreadsheet would have done that
yeah i i think i'm being ripped off if
i'm being honest i
i think an hourly wage would be a bit
more sufficient because this is this is
bankrupt to me chris if i'm being honest
it's the exponential increase in cost
isn't it because she's not happy
hearing is what a way to start a podcast
all right
[ __ ] it i mean what else are we here for
um so
i wanted to talk today about the
development of your fitness journey
there's a concept
that you might not be familiar with at
least by name but probably by type
who everyone listening will be and it's
called the fitness menopause
and i wanted to hear from someone who
has been to
peak condition wbff worlds am i right
and saying
yeah yeah
was it was the worlds in las vegas yeah
so you know top top end physique
competitor
um and i want you to hear about sort of
your fitness menopause journey and just
get us a riff on
on some fitness industry stuff so the
fitness menopause i'll give you a big
overview
um i noticed amongst myself and my
friends that as
i got towards my late 20s into my 30s
i became chronically aware of my own
mortality i realized that training
purely for aesthetics
was losing its appeal that i was feeling
quite unfulfilled i wanted to have a
more robust physique
i also wanted to be able to kind of
bulletproof myself
physio physiologically from the onset of
aches and pains and stuff that was
happening
um so i started to pivot my training i
pivoted away from
bodybuilding fitness style training and
into i started doing thai boxing and
boxing and crossfit
and other bits and pieces and i found
really fulfilled
i actually found that my progress and my
training volume went up because i was
enjoying what i was doing
and i was no longer focused on these
socialized externalized metrics of
success
it was more the internalized performance
based metrics of success
this i've seen happen across a whole ton
of friends that start doing yoga friends
that start doing pilates or free running
or
uh calisthenics or whatever it might be
and it just seems to be a very
common um change
that men specifically seem to go through
i think girls
actually as far as i can see seem to be
a little bit more integrated
with their fitness they if they're a
dancer when they're a kid they're still
dancing when they're in their early
twenties and they're still teaching
dancer and they're in the
30s and 40s or whatever but guys
definitely seem to have a
menopause that they go through and then
after that there's this sort of whole
new world that they
they step into so i wondered sort of
what your experience has been how you
sort of your fitness journey started and
then where it's taken you now
so i think my fitness genocide when i
was 13. so
i used to go to the gym i used to be a
really hyperactive
kids and they used to open up the gym
in in the lunch hour and one of the one
of the pe teachers used to go in there
so every lunchtime i was in the gym
training
i'd only actually it's weird i'd only
train legs um i wouldn't train up a body
really weird for a 13 year old i know
but i had this party trick i'll get all
my mates on the leg press machine and
could do 20 reps so it's kind of like
that's that's some some epic school uh
um i was going to say street cred is
more like a school cred there
and that it's always been a fundamental
part of my life gym and training
now when i joined the army i joined the
army at 17.
of course you needed to be fit for duty
so
i really got into the gym from the age
of 13 but really got it into it in the
army but
you had to be able to lift and shift in
the army so it's always no good having
big muscles unless you could you know
carry someone for 200 meters pretty
quick with it
so i'd always had that mentality of you
know being
strong and fit and not just kind of uh
[Music]
show off muscles so to speak and it's
kind of um
weird because of course when i left the
army i started competing where
you know you're not focused on
performance you're focused on aesthetics
and
for me it was always this case where i
was a big lump in the army a big fit
lump that was always training but i'd
look at
these magazines and these guys like how
on earth does somebody look like that i
train harder than that person
and i didn't actually really realize it
that it was diet my idea of bulking in
the army was going to burger king with
the land rover
you know three times a week um and that
obviously
wasn't working so when i left the army
i you know i kind of lost a bit of my
identity because i've been a soldier
from a teenager and
suddenly going yeah at the time i was
working in it for a year and
i needed to find something about me you
know oh that's jamie he's a soldier it
was always and instead of
this jamie's working in the it
department it kind of felt a little bit
you know a little bit different and
that's when i started getting into
competing because it was like a
imaginary sergeant on my shoulder saying
you've got to get up early
you've got to eat this and you've got to
do that and i loved it because it
just gave me structure and routine like
my military life
and my first competition that i did was
the bnbf which was the british natural
bodybuilding competition
i came second in the novice uh qualified
for the british
um i didn't place the british but the
week before i won
the overall novice muscle mania
natural championship and from from then
on it was all about competing and
seeing how i could push my body um
and you know it was never about
competing with others it was always
about competing with myself
so i think my journey there was trying
to make something of myself
you know coming out of the army and
becoming a soldier and my identity was
very much attached
with the way that i look because of
course i was in all these magazines and
everything else like that
but that comes with another issue as
well because when your identity is
attached
to the way that you look and you let's
just say you're in an off season or
you know you've put a couple of you know
20 pounds 25 pounds on you you're not
yourself
because you have created this figment in
your head of what you think others
view you as even though that might not
be true so that comes with its own
issues when suddenly you get
an email or that about a photo shoot and
you're suddenly like 10 pounds
you know off shoot shape shall we say
and you go to extremes to get back there
to get back to the person who you think
you are
so my fitness journey from kind of
soldier
to competitor was very much about that
trying to find
what i'm you know what i'm known for
beyond being a soldier
and you know as i carried on pushing
that
2013 was when my daughter eliza was born
and that year was one of the kind of the
happiest
pinnacle moments in the change in my
fitness because although i was still
competing
for two more years after that that 2013
i gained 50 pounds
so i kind of went from 190 to like 136
pounds or something like that
it was a great year because i stopped
focusing on myself kind of a very
selfish competitor and started focusing
on my family
my wife and my clients and what happened
during that year is i was
felt really fulfilled although i wasn't
in
you know fitness model shape so to speak
i doubled my business because
all of my focus was on getting my
clients fit and healthy and i had a
great home life because i was focusing
on
you know my newborn daughter and it was
kind of a this thing of
jamie you know you don't your success
isn't based on what you look like it's
based on how you make others feel
and that was kind of a [ __ ] yeah you're
right here
um but i was 236 pounds
and i did want to get back on stage
again so i i had uh 2014
i stepped on the world stage which we
which we spoke about and
got myself back in shape um had a more
flexible approach
because i'm very much before that hand
very extreme
and i couldn't do that with a daughter
you know my daughter and i didn't want
to have those real bad energy
drops and although as you do in the last
few weeks i kind of balance things out
a lot and i'd say ever since 2014 i've
been in pretty good shape because it's
my habits and routines that keep me
there not the extremes in which i need
to go
and i think you know fast forward now
from say
2015 to today you know i maintain a good
physique i've got strong healthy habits
but i'm a lot more relaxed about things
yes i've still got this
kind of compete with myself mentality
and i channel that in other things that
i do
fitness-wise um but you know if you're
to ask me would i
get shredded and you know beyond
shredded again and step on stage the
answer would be no
a you know i love gin at the weekends
and b i'm not willing to put my family
through
the sacrifices that it takes for that to
get essentially a plastic trophy and a
pat on the back
what were some of the sacrifices that
you had to make to get to the sort of
condition where you were walking on
stage
which is hyper hype appealed
what yeah what did it fit what does it
feel like
i would say like
the way the way i can explain it is that
natural competitors one thing that
they're good at is suffering
you the better that somebody looks
natural and you know come from a bmbf
background these guys are peeled but
they
sometimes can't even get out of bed um
and in order to get that kind of
condition you need to suffer
and it comes a massive sacrifice
your kind of mental health gets affected
a little bit because you're constantly
looking in the mirror i'd say like
now i'll probably have a glance in the
mirror while i'm brushing my teeth in
the morning the next time i glance in
the mirror
is when i go to bed and brush my teeth
um and there you are literally every car
you walk past everything you walk past
you're always
you know because your motivation is
based on how you look
and you're being judged on your and how
you look so
you are constantly checking yourself out
to make sure that you look okay because
if you don't then it's like well hang on
what am i doing all this for so there's
a huge mind game there
and when you get very very lean you
crave a lot of weird foods
you crave a lot of foods because
although you can factor certain ones in
you've only got a certain amount of
calories there's a lot of things that
you can't
and that plays on your mind because when
you can't have something you want it
and you start to crave you have these
mad cravings you start
you know you stop looking at tv programs
you just watch food
programs you write food lists of things
that you're going to eat when you finish
you know all of these kind of things and
i used to be what's called a cake
sniffer so i used to actually go
bite buy cakes for other people and i'd
be happy just as long as i could sniff
them
so it's these kind of things that affect
you and a couple of weeks before
um you know our daughter i was carrying
my daughter around town and we went from
one shop to the other and i was
exhausted
i said i'm knackered yeah an hour later
i was ripping deadlifts off the floor
so there's there's lots of things that
are involved with that and you think
well what
what is all of this for and
if i'm being honest you know to the
untrained eye
you could look shredded like photo shoot
shape
and you could look the epitome of health
and actually be the epitome of health if
you've got a good amount of muscle
tissue and for me
my shoot shape is around let's just say
about 196 pounds that was when i was on
the front cover of muscle and fitness
magazine
yet my stage weight is 180.
so if you were to look at me you know
front cover
i look shredded but if you were to say
if i was to say no actually i'd need to
lose another 16 pounds you would like
where where from and i'm like i will
tell you where
like this is about another 14 weeks
of being in a calorie deficit and
training in order to achieve that so
when you understand that you're like
well why
like if you look absolutely great at
that why would you ever go anywhere
below and the only time you would would
be for
you know for a competition um and
you know i found other ways of
scratching that itch now
oh you know since 2016. so
that's a lot more selfless you know i do
every every two years i do a big charity
event
um that pushes me mentally and
physically
because i always do like stupid things
shall we say
but it raises a lot of money for charity
and raises a lot of money for
one of my local children's charities so
it has a lot of it
has a lot of selfish itches that get
scratched but it has even more selfless
because actually other people benefit
from it which
you know other people suffer when i you
know when i used to compete there was no
benefit to it whatsoever apart from
my own selfish games privatized gains
and socialized losses as naval ravicant
would call it
how much of an influence was your
daughter being born on this
red pill moment the the the menopause
onset
a lot i mean up until that time i was
i would say i was a very extremely
driven selfish arrogant person
that cared nothing but his own
achievements despite just like having a
misses
yeah yeah yeah i mean how is she still
with me i don't know like
i really like i always say you know
whenever i do a post i'm like because
i've been with my wife since
13 okay since the age of 13 says she's
grown up with me and i think
you know there's one person that knows a
real me it's my wife and a lot of people
who actually asked her said
you know anna's is just shifting gears a
little bit
but a lot of people said to my wife how
have you stayed together so long and she
said well i've married six different men
it's very fascinating as you said that
because she goes well you know i got
with a boy
i you know then grew up with a person
who was joining the army
and then leaving the army and then i
married a competitor
then i married a business owner and then
and it was this whole transition into
that thing and
i've changed as a person throughout that
journey
and you know if you want to know a key
to relationship it
can be evolving and growing together and
not staying the same it can be a very
strong thing because
you know if you'd say oh you know you've
been together 22 years it doesn't feel
like it because we've gone through
different evolutions of that
so um yeah it's always been a
fascinating thing to to understand that
but going back to what we said you know
being extremely selfish i think a lot of
that was i had to
prove to myself i was worthy of things
because i think a lot of people they
stay in this kind of rut
of teetering between selfishness and
selflessness because they're not willing
to give their complete selfish
you know complete selfishness to achieve
something that's going to make them more
selfless if that
makes sense um because in order to help
people at a lower level you need to play
at a high level and sometimes in order
to play and win at a high level you need
to make a lot of sacrifice
whatever it is that you're focused on
achieving and um
i think it was a very there's a very
interesting podcast with tim ferriss and
walter o'brien i don't know if you know
what
o'brien is he's um basically at the age
of six
he hacked he was basically he hacked
into a computer in ireland and
um fbi knocked on his door and he was
actually downloading
um nasa uh space programs on his uh
dot matrix principles uh i think he's uh
he's got an iq of 197 and
fascinating podcast he was talking about
how far we're away from
head transplants and what would be
required to do that but
he said a quote about in order to and it
stuck with me because it's quite
polarizing
and what he said is it was about mother
teresa he said
mother teresa hugged a thousand people
in their time and they still died
bill gates wrote a check which wiped out
malaria
and he said it he thinks it's important
that you should spend
a part of your life being completely
selfish
so you can spend the rest of it being
completely selfless and it's a very
fascinating quote that he said because
it's like right so
if the answer to be more helpful to
people is to be extremely selfish
what is it that you're going to do on
this planet
for yourself in order to do that and
that that's one thing that i've noticed
with a lot of people when you
talk about they've evolved in their
fitness i feel like i've got to a stage
where i'm happy that i've achieved
enough to be confident no matter what i
do in fitness
i i will feel like it's enough if that
makes sense
there's a quote that completely slots
into what you're saying
it is easier to fulfill your material
desires than to renounce them
yeah exactly and um you know i don't
feel i've got any more to prove
with my fitness journey other than to
keep
on top of it to stay on this planet as
long as possible and every couple of
years
just just let people know that i'm not
dead yet
and it's like you know the worst thing
that anybody could say to me
in the next 10 20 30 years is you're
past it because i will not only come
back
i will look you in the face and go i
told you so um and
i've been driven by spite for a lot of
things and the main reason being is that
i've
back back when we're talking about when
i was 236 pounds we were at the first
european wbff show in the uk
and i was hammered i was at the bar
pissed i ran about 10 points of guinness
i was telling all the competitors i'll
be back on the world stage next year
kicking all of your asses
and they laugh their tits off yeah yeah
all right jay whatever
like is in your past set and i can
remember i even remember that now
and i had three of them text me two
weeks four whiles and goes fair play
and it was just didn't need to say it
but it's like yeah and
and other things with regards to my
you know my charity events box jumping
everest no one had ever boxed something
ever it's not i don't think anyone was
stupid enough and
in order to do it i needed to box on 14
550 box jumps in less than 24 hours and
you know if anybody's done 10 box jumps
they'll know how difficult that was so i
had a lot of people
even after i'd done it saying i did not
think you could do that
and i and the only reason
well apart from the most important one
raising the money for
charity and you know me feeling
compelled to do it
because there's no way that i couldn't
because i wouldn't let down those
children
but that spite of going just because you
said that's not possible somebody can't
do it doesn't mean that i can't
um and i think that comes down to
complete self-belief that if you
commit to understanding what it takes to
do something then you're able to achieve
it because most things are based on
fundamentals
and anything endurance wise
is based on the said principle which is
essentially a specific adaptation to
impose demands
you impose enough progressive load on
and stress on the body
over time it will adapt it will improve
and
it will increase you've just got to know
where to push those buttons
how long you need and
essentially have that talent which a lot
of competitors have and that's the
ability to suffer
that's one thing that i would say if you
if we had
if we were playing top trumps and we had
one of those little things that's what
that's one of my high
powers it's just the ability to suffer
for a long period of time
it's interesting to see what happens
when you break down a big accomplishment
into small steps
like you could if you were given enough
time you could walk to mars you know
like if you were given a couple of eons
you could walk to mars it's just one
step in front of the other can you take
a step
yes right okay that's all that walking
to mars is it's just a
whole bunch of steps the same as your
box jumping
everest fourteen thousand and a bit box
jumps with
22 and a half hours it took you yeah
that was right yeah
tell us about that tell us how that felt
um so i've done a few this was my third
big 24-hour event that i've done and so
i had a bit to compare it to but i would
say out of the three
it was it was the hardest one that i'd
done because
the other two i could slow the pace down
so if i was feeling a bit tired
i could just reduce the pace down so you
know i pushed
um a sled for 24 hours and for that you
know
you adapt to it but also you for the
first four or five hours you can pick up
a higher pace so when you're exhausted
you can pick up those lost laps from the
beginning
but this you needed to hit 660 per hour
or you weren't going to get the record
so there were there was no oh i just
need to slow down this hour you had to
hit
a threshold and that threshold was
between 13 and 15 box jumps every minute
so that's a lot of pressure because
i had a couple of hours there an hour
nine an hour ten
um my quad went um into a spasm my calf
had gone
and i just and it was the most
excruciating
hour where in your head you're like
you've got
12 more hours of this and it's the
narrative that you put in your head
and as you were saying with breaking
things down i didn't look at it as oh
i've got 10 hours left i'm
like you've got 36 more
rounds before you can take a 10 minute
rest because
our effective strategy which we realized
was that
we need to give ourselves adequate rest
so instead of trying to do 660 box jumps
in an hour
we need to do 660 box jumps in 50
minutes
so we need to go a faster pace just so
we can get that 10 minutes to
feed go to the toilet rest recover and
sort out any niggles or injuries that
we've got
so that hour it was just yeah you've got
just got to
you've just got to smash through these
36 rounds and then you can sit down
you can get a massage and then you can
get ready for the next evolution
and that's something that i loved
hearing about
i love that talk i think it's general
mccreavy or mccravey talking about
um never ring the bell um and he says
basically with navy seals you go through
hell week and you basically don't sleep
for five you get
about two hours sleeping five days which
a lot of people don't think well no you
don't just get to and like you do
people don't think that it's possible
for a body to stay up that well there's
plenty of seals that will show you that
that is true
and he says the ones that make it is you
know if you want to quit at any time in
those five days
you just ring a bell and he says the
people that passed that
there was never a bell in their head
there wasn't a bell there it was just
can
continue to go on and i think if i'm
kind of breaking that down
my my second chariot event i actually
put a bell at the start line
and i painted a picture saying there is
no bell so that was a great reminder
from the last one to say look
you know i passed that bell every single
lap and i was never going to ring it
but i've always had that in my head is
just like right
it's not you've got to continue on
you've just got to do the next hour
and it comes down to this one chapter a
day analogy that i do with a lot of
things
you know small thing we all know that
small things don't consistently turn
into big results but people
just aren't patient enough to hit the
small things consistently
and what i say to people is look if
you're committed to reading one chapter
of a book a day the average
self-development book 11 to 12 chapters
means you're going to get between 30 and
34 books reading a year
but if you just go in with a mentality
of here's the 34 books that need to
change my life i'm just going to try and
get through them throughout the year
you'll probably only get five or ten
done and it just comes down to that
strategy as you said chris people aren't
willing to be patient enough for results
and persistent enough to hit a small
minimum effective dose every day
ethan supply the actor from butterfly
effect and wolf of wall street and the
huge huge guy from
remember the titans who's now 236 pounds
he's lost 300 pounds
and he's 10 body fat he'd be amazing to
get on your show actually
i can do an intro if you're interested
he's a phenomenal dude amazing guy
big into his training big into his
health and fitness and he
had a martial arts instructor for a
movie that he was doing
and this sensei guy um he was wearing
this t-shirt and this t-shirt said
um kill your clone on it i was like
what's that he's like oh it's my
sensei's little saying that he's got
that every day
you wake up and you have to have a fight
with you from yesterday
it's a clone of you and if you haven't
made that marginal gain if you haven't
slept slightly better become slightly
more mindful become slightly fitter
become slightly smarter or whatever it
might be
if you go to bed worse than when you
woke up your clone kills you he's like
that's not the way it works it's like
you kill your clone
every day and you know everyone that's
been on this show
james smith good examples someone who
from a business and notoriety standpoint
has done some fairly sort of
astronomical celestial things
but he says himself what i do isn't that
impressive it's just my consistency at
doing it over time effectively
james clee has been on this show author
of atomic habits my favorite book from
the last couple of years
and he says the same thing it's just
like just show up just do the thing the
minimum
effective dose go to the gym and do a
press-up and then go home go to the gym
and do two press-ups and then go home
and the same with what you've done the
progressive overload
is king in all areas of life and that's
like the best thing
i think the the best um unifying
principle
that i learned from bodybuilding and
fitness training is the concept of
progressive overload like really really
understanding what that means
that just that tonnage each week can i
do that with reading can i do that with
the precision in my speech
can i do that with the relationships
that i have with everybody else because
that is
that is what development means in a very
a very sort of pure sense the capacity
to do more than you were previously able
to do
i had a guest on who had a other
interesting view on it he said
self-development is the ability to hold
more complexity
than yesterday which is a part of that
but also a little bit of a nuance which
i love but
yeah man progressive overload king in
everything
yeah and you know i a lot of things that
i used to do it's just because
you know it's very easy to be consistent
with things that you enjoy
doing because you become more motivated
and i think one of the
biggest things that happened with you
know a lot of people would say to me oh
you know how did you deal with lockdown
and i'm like well i think you go through
different phases but also
you know i kind of started in a really
euphoric mood and it kind of went down a
bit
and then it went back up why we saw
euphoric at the start
because um being being a soldier
an ex-soldier when lockdown happened
i kind of switch gears into there's
gonna be a lot of people that need my
help
um this shit's easy for me you know
doing
six-month tour of uh baghdad we were
you know sleeping in a in a tiny little
porter cabin
with six other lads for six months with
mortars dropping left right and center
of us every single day i'm like
this is nothing i'm sitting in my house
with netflix with with a high-speed
um broadband i live 15 minutes from the
beach and i'm allowed to go for a c dip
in the morning
i'm [ __ ] good but i know a lot of
people who need my help now and and
that's why i was in a
like oh this is the only time where i
feel that the world has slowed down
and i can kind of get ahead a little bit
and i and i did but one of the mistakes
i think i made is that i did
and i'm only kind of coming out now is
the fact that i i was getting back into
those habits of doing too much
not having a day off um
ultra productive and kind of being very
selfless to the wrong people and not
selfish to the right people
um and i learned a lot
from 2016 in doing that so i
saw the commonalities between that and
kind of was like whoa hang on a minute
there jay
there's lots of opportunities here but
don't
but don't forget why you're doing all
this for and it's for for a better life
for your family not just for you
so it kind of like backed off a little
bit drink
i was drinking quite heavily as well i'm
a big i mean i ex-squad is always a
drink and it's always an excuse to get
drunk
um but i've kind of
probably a month before probably no more
than that about six seven weeks ago i
was just like no
stop this jay focus on your fitness
focus on your health and
you're so much better at what it is that
you do
when you're sober you know when you're
not having a few drinks and it's very
easy like we talk about habits
you know having a few beers at night
makes you feel awesome
it does because you don't really wake up
with that much of a hangover
um i get quite creative after a glass of
wine as well
i very much like when the missus is out
having a bottle of albect to myself and
a good book
because then i fell out three i fill out
like three or four pages of notepad
and sometimes that can be a bad
justification for doing something that
you know yeah you end up having a bottle
and then you
adapt to that and then it's not a bottle
on a friday night it's a bottle three
times a week and then it's like but uh
yeah but a bottle every night and
if you can clang on you if you can
clamber on to a justification for it
that's productive
then you can keep that habit and you
allow yourself and
something that i learnt a lot about my
own habits is just because you can
doesn't mean you should
i remember reading an article about hi
um so
you hear the word function in alcoholic
people who can still
just about do their job and function as
as one
and i remember reading this book about
high performance
um function high performance functioning
alcoholics and these are athletes
you know these are iron man athletes and
people who are literally alcoholics but
also they're just gifted in what they do
and it doesn't affect them and and it
made me ponder like well i'm not an iron
man i'm not an ultra marathon
runner and this but i get where their
tendencies come from because
there's no negative feedback loop in
what it is that they're doing and
sometimes you need to actually just say
to yourself
[ __ ] stop and that's the hardest
thing to do when there's nothing there's
no
cue to say that this is detrimental and
i found that with a lot of things
especially with my fat loss
because i've been training for the age
of 13. um it doesn't take me long to get
back in shape you know i say
say to people six weeks of tracking
macros and that and
i'd be on the front couple of muscle and
fitness
because that's what i did for six weeks
before before actually being on there
but that's what happens when you've been
weight training
for 22 years you've developed a decent
amount of muscle tissue and habits
during that time so it's a lot easier to
do
you know you just stop drinking on the
weekends and uh
increase your output and you know
stop eating macky d's three times a week
and there you go
so i always have to kind of check myself
before i wreck myself with these things
and that's one thing that i found that
level of self-awareness
is key not just to myself but to
everyone because no one's
like i i've said for the last five years
write [ __ ] down but people still don't
and it's some it's a practice which i
think every single person should do
to get that stuff out of your head onto
a piece of paper
makes such a difference and this is why
you're just looking here i've got
three whiteboards and i can just see
three notepads with different things on
my
desk for different for different reasons
so i've got a pondering notepad i've got
a notes notepad and i've got an
education one which i make notes on for
um stuff that i want to progress in my
business
a lot that you've covered there is stuff
that everyone listening will be familiar
with
i'm a huge advocate of sobriety as a
productivity tool
i'm a club promoter by trade so i've
watched
millions of people going to nightclubs
but found a few years ago that if i went
sober i had more time money and calories
to spend on things that i care about
so again if the people listening haven't
got bored of me saying
already sobriety is a wonderful
productivity tool you're looking at
someone who has a lot of different
plates to continue spinning and jamie
appears to have have you gone
full sobriety now just absolutely no
weekend only what's the rule that you
went for
um i've toyed with the idea because i
think i said to myself what would be the
hardest thing
for you to do and i was like don't drink
for a year and
i've i've said to myself look having a
drink is a fundamental part of my life
and
and people could argue that it's not but
i
genuinely enjoy it when it's you know
if you're a per i'm always a fan of
reduce or remove and i can
genuinely and i have done for for a long
time
to have routines and rituals in my head
that gets results and saying to myself
not drinking on a school night
which is monday to from monday to
thursday
and no more than like a bottle of wine
with the misses or if you're gonna go
out
one gin and tonic or two and having
these kind of
if i'm getting in shape for three months
you're not allowed to get drunk you'll
have to get tipsy but not drunk and
that's
maximum two drinks and that mean that
gives me the the benefit
of it but none of the disadvantages
so if you're able to do that then yes
and if you're not
and you know i've had these these
moments
then you need to go to extremes to do it
there's an interesting
um interview i saw with richard branson
um and he was talking about alcohol
and he said when he's had a when he's
been you know drunk a bit too much and
he's been a bit hungover he instantly
had has no alcohol for 12 weeks
because it makes him realize someone in
his position just doesn't make sense to
be unproductive for a day
because that that to him at his level
affects so many more people you know it
affects others lives
because his decision his decisions yeah
he's putting up bloody rockets to mars
for christ's sake
so you know when you start thinking
about others for that it gives you
motivation to
to kind of stop and yeah it's always
been a an interesting one for me
um alcohol because you know a lot of it
comes comes from a military background i
do have a
you know me and mrs do enjoy a bottle of
wine on the weekends
and you know i'm a big fan of gin
but it's yeah i think it's so important
to notice your bad habits too um and i
would say like
if i was to say right what are your you
know worst habits jamie i'd say right
definitely alcohol is one of them most
certainly um
impatience with others probably another
one um and
i think what stoicism has has taught me
is the ability to control what you can
control and let go of things that you
can't
um so that's always a thing which
is a narrative in my head what i do you
know when i'm starting to feel
frustrated because someone hasn't
done something or got back to me which
has affected my own thing i'm like well
is it that important jamie and the
answer is usually no so it's the i think
it's he's
he said focus is he's he's pulling these
different mental models in your life
to be able to perform and understand
you know your own life and your own
progress i think that would be an
interesting challenge for you to do i
think six months
of sobriety would be an interesting
eye-opening experience for you too yeah
i mean for you to go through
i mean i've done six and eight months
before because of competing ah yeah
because yes as soon as i compete that's
it i
do not have alcohol you know it's it's
it's literally a
a switch and it's done and i am that
kind of person that will just go right
done but
if it's not for an outcome-based reason
this is what i need to
kind of really do some work on and
challenge myself yes
because yes okay there are sacrifices in
but to be honest what you're saying to
you know in certain situation what
you're saying is that you can't enjoy
the environment that you're in without
it and it's like well you can do you
just got to change your mindset around
what it is
that you're trying to listening everyone
are you listening to the same words i've
been saying for the last three years
coming out of jamie alden's mouth
yeah man absolutely absolutely alcohol
is a social performance enhancing drug
and without the um without a
concentrated period where you're forced
to do the things that you usually do
with alcohol
without alcohol you'll never develop
that confidence
to go up and speak to that girl the
ability to be to feel like you are
as interesting extroverted capable of
dealing with a boring situation
like you don't realize that your friends
big group of your friends you're only
friends with them
because you get pissed together like
it's one of these things and i think
that kind of removing that veil
it'd be interesting to see where your
internal work goes with that man i will
be i'll be really really interested to
see sort of what
what that journey goes through and i
think as well not having the goal
like when you were going through full
monk mode and you're like right now cake
sniffing cake and um no alcohol and this
that any other
it's a very different pathway to i'm
going to do this for the reason that i
want to see what life is like without it
and et cetera et cetera
so yeah that'll be that'll be an
interesting one but so
the um the alcohol thing was was an
interesting
uh part that you brought up there and
then just breaking stuff down man you
know breaking things down into small
manageable chunks
um i wonder
as your sort of fitness journey and
business journey and stuff like that
now continues to mature what do you
think's next have you got your next
big um charity event thing organized you
got any ideas what that might be
so this this year has been a rest
rest year from that and then next year
i'm focused on something
um and i've kind of set the bar with the
box jump
uh i was looking at a few things there
was i i'll say one because it's not
going to happen
i watched a documentary on captain webb
who was one of the first person to
breaststroke the
um the the english channel back in night
am i right insane the reason that he did
breast
stroke was because it was it was on
gentlemen it was
unbecoming of a gentleman to put your
head below the water and it was like
chavy to do the front crawl
yeah yeah and uh
and if you know and it was like right
hang on a minute so
i've ticked some boxes here uh i don't
frunk crawl i don't
i'm a breaststroker so that that's good
i'm a strong breaststroker
uh i i go for a dip in the sea every
single morning
without fail um and you know it kind of
falls in line with the things i
you know just following a a legend and
it's got a story and a narrative but
it's just uh my my good friend ross
edgeley swimming's his thing
and you know i'm very much like i need
my own thing
and although it's totally different
obviously he swam all the way around the
uk
but he you know it's not it's that's his
thing
and it's and it's always kind of strange
because there's a couple of people
training to do my box jump everest now
and i i i just find it amazing go for it
and wish you the best of luck but it
just you know it's just
not something that i'd want to do like
i'd be inspired by someone but do your
own thing
um so that thing i mean i'm toying with
the idea of
getting a rickshaw and
setting a geometry rickshaw you know the
old
chinese transportation but it's a wheel
it's a wheelie one
like it's a bicycle with a cart on the
back
yeah so i want to do in a 48 hour
endurance event with that i just got to
try to think of a good
beginning and end for it um and it has
to be challenging enough to do
the people in it no people in the
rickshaw yeah people in the rickshaw
yeah so i
that's the that that's the thing that's
toying in my head at the moment i
i don't know the distance you know i'm
probably about 70 miles from london
so it might be a good thing to do
especially finish in london but i don't
know that's the thing that's in my head
at the moment
there there were the two things that
that might just be totally something
different but
i'll have determined that around the
christmas time with
you know the december time is my ponder
time and pondering plan for the next
year so there'll be something that comes
into my head
then it has to be some it has to be
something that someone says that can't
be done
um and i think you know if i was to say
i'm going to put rickshaw to london
i think most people would think i could
do it which means i shouldn't do it push
it a little bit further i've got to come
up with something a little bit more
ludicrous
yeah yeah so we'll see i mean i've got
over 18 months to kind of figure it out
um so wherever wherever it will be it'll
be
that's cool man looping back to the
journey
through fitness and this kind of i'm
really interested in this dynamic
between
the externalized socialized measures of
success
and the internalized fulfilling measures
of success what would you say
to some of the people that are listening
perhaps who
are still um very heavily attaching
their
sense of identity and their sense of
self-worth to their condition
are there any sort of um light bulb
moments
that happened for you or anything that
you any sort of lessons that you'd pass
on to those people
yeah no one cares no one cares
at all imagine if you will that you
can't swim
and i've chucked you in the deep end and
all you're doing
is flapping your arms trying to get
breath now imagine
7.5 billion people doing that
metaphorically every single day
your wants and needs are your wants and
needs
everybody else has got so much [ __ ] in
their life that even if you were a
passing for
you'll be sl you'll be quickly forgotten
with
the amount of problems that that person
has to solve each day
so if you're hindering yourself based on
the things that other people who aren't
even
considering you are thinking then you're
doing yourself a disservice
because no one cares and that has
enabled me
to completely change my view of doing
things
because i do it for me not anybody else
and
the reason that i do these things is to
explore myself
not what other people's opinions are of
me because they don't matter because
they don't care because
it's a passing thought we would care far
less about what other people think about
us if we realized how infrequently they
do
yeah exactly and and um
i very much love a lot of the stoic
philosophies
with things um and the view from above
is always a great one where
you kind of you you you lie down
and you kind of look up a hundred feet
in the air
and then you look at what you can see
and then you go a thousand feet in the
air
and then you go two thousand miles above
and then you go to the next galaxy and
you realize you're you're [ __ ] all
you're a speck of dust which is gone in
a second
so if you are you know having those
doubts and thoughts and fears which are
hindering you it adds to that it doesn't
care because
you're gonna you're gone in a bleep so
just make the most of it so what should
people spend their time on if they're
not spending their time on
on the things that other people that
they think or the people are bothered
about what should they spend their time
doing
things that give you happiness and
fulfillment
um fulfillment has come from progress
becoming a better version of yourself
making mistakes and fuck-ups and
failures
being able to do things which you know
you couldn't
fathom that you could do before and you
can do now
um doing difficult things
and also doing things regardless of how
you feel because the outcome is more
important
um focusing on those things
have made me very content and happy and
also because
doing things for other people as well as
you mentioned before and i think that's
the thing
um i love the quote give and forget
receive and remember
i think with with business and marketing
everyone understands the reciprocity you
you scratch my back and one you know
your scratch
yours but i think the people who make a
difference is they're basically back
scratchers they don't want their back
scratched
they just want to give out good things
to the world
and it's rare to find those people but
when you do make sure that you're mates
with them because they don't want you
know
something i say to a lot of my friends
you know i do a lot of things for people
and they're like what do you want i'm
like look
i'm good if i want something yeah i will
ask you directly for it but i'm good i
can figure out you know i
prefer to figure it out for myself and
if i need a little nudge just point me
in the right direction
um because it you know it feels good to
do
you know when you've got skills and
talents that help other people
you get such a selfish
benefit from it that they don't know
about it's the oddly
circular thing of doing things for other
people that it's very much
for yourself there's a study that said
it's a 10x return giving a gift
as opposed to buying it for yourself you
spend a pound on yourself is the
equivalent as
and spending a pound on someone else is
like spending 10
on you um and yeah it is it is bizarre
that the most selfish thing you can do
is be selfless
yeah and it's so counter-intuitive you
know if i have a
a coach or that that's been struggling
that suddenly
have picked up a few hundred clients and
their business has doubled
um and now they can take their wife and
kid on holiday
or they could you know and it's just
like that's what it's all about
and for me you know that's transitioning
the b2b market with helping people
and that's a strange market to be in
because you know everyone on surface
level looks like they're wanting to do
the same things for people but building
a business of competitors yeah
yeah and it's just like well that's what
it's all about you know there's a great
book
uh the go-giver which i love um and it
has a huge business narrative in that
about look
it doesn't matter if they're it
competitors you know if you are good and
you're
even as a competitor to patent them on
the back they'll always remember that
if they're the right person that you're
mentored so that's all good you know
success breeds success and if you're not
caught up by it or intimidated by it
everybody wins and it's having that
mentality
um and practicing that and
listening to your own thoughts and
feelings about others as well
so i'm very much motivated by envy i
think envy can be a help and a hindrance
in life where you see
things that other people want and you
want them for yourselves
and i think the mistake that a lot of
people make is that
they're looking at materialistic things
rather than kind of holistic things
um i had someone say to me oh so-and-so
is doing so well you know it's got all
these clients he's on all these things
i'm like well
in order for you to have what they have
you and this comes from naval ravicon
actually
in order for you to have what that
person has you need to completely change
your life and i said to my friend well
you've got two kids and a wife
in order for you to have what that
person has you have to give them up too
because you can't just pick the things
that you want
from that person you've got to pick the
life
and when you realize that it's like it
allows you to think the things that you
do have because i think when you're
envious about a person you'll just focus
on one variable without the entire
package that comes with that you don't
know what that is you don't know what
the price is man i did i wrote an entire
article
around that one quote from naval on
uh the knowledge project with shane
parish you cannot take part of someone's
life you have to take the whole
you don't know what the price is to be
elon musk you don't know if he's
disgusted when he looks in the mirror if
he can't go to bed at night if he's got
rampant erectile dysfunction if he
doesn't have a relationship with his
father where he can't speak to him
you don't like you love the idea of
being conor mcgregor but do you want to
spend
years and years rolling the same
techniques and throwing the same
combinations
whilst living in your parents like attic
in ireland you want to be that instagram
influencer
but do you really do you know what
they're like what if they haven't had an
orgasm in months what if they
can't bear to eat food without feeling
sick about themselves what if they're
terrified that they've leveraged their
entire sense of self-worth
to outsource to a bunch of people who
they don't even know on the internet
like all of these things are the unseen
prices that you would have to pay
to be that person you can't just have
elon musk's work ethic and his and his
money
you have to take the entire package and
i think realizing that
it's a bit interesting about what you
said about envy there about how it's
useful
i certainly find myself now being
envious of
uh perhaps your ability to deal with
discomfort uh your ability to
um be resilient to uh uh
setbacks and have that third party
perspective that's the sort of thing
that i i agree there is a degree of envy
um
where it can be useful it's the right
it's the right thing to be envious of
not a ferrari or a house or
you know how many followers you have and
i think that's understanding
you know like why why are you envious
about that thing you know and it's
a lot of the things that people are
envious about is of
having that thing of how it looks to
other people
and it comes back to that thing of
you're trying to impress people that
don't
care and you don't and they don't and
you don't actually
like you know and how much of that so
how much of that realization
is just getting older i you know i i
i think it is this kind of thing i think
it's that realization that
you know like i i started on tick tock
last year and i didn't realize i was old
until i joined tick tock
and i was just like [ __ ] some people
calling me like all right boomer and i
was like [ __ ] i'm
like jesus yeah and i think yeah i think
a lot of it has to do with it because
you know as you do get older you do get
what you know older wiser but then
you've made more mistakes and you've got
more experience and
and i think as well as you i think the
true wisdom will start to come when
other people around you are dying
of old age when other people are getting
sick and ill and you actually then
realize that life is short
um and i think you know a lot of people
are
scared about getting old and i'm i'm so
looking forward to it obviously i want
to fast forward my life towards it but
i i just think you know in in the in my
50s and 60s it's going to be
incredible can you imagine how much
wisdom you'll have accrued
by that point how how mindful you'll be
how capable of helping others you'll be
um i i agree man that's the the beauty
and the common theme that some of the
listeners may have pulled out of this
conversation is that having a growth
mindset bulletproofs you against a lot
of things
it's bulletproof to your relationship
with your misses
from like children to 22 years down the
line
because you've both allowed yourselves
to grow together that has been a common
theme
the same thing with your physical
pursuits yeah maybe the specifics like
the flavor of it has changed but the
the direction and the journey has kind
of stayed relatively the same
so on and so forth that having a growth
mindset is a superpower
as is being curious as is a couple of
other
a couple of other elements that you can
add into your life but
man i am i really think i i keep asking
myself this question the reason i asked
about the
getting older thing is with the advent
of so much self-development i can see
seth
golden and and james clear's atomic
habits just behind you on the desk
with the advent of self-development what
we're trying to do is hurry the onset of
this wisdom right we're trying to
expedite our access to wisdom at a
younger age
this is why some of the people that are
in my modern wisdom big dicks group that
help with the project
they're like 24 years old this guy
george 24 years old
and he's just he's a [ __ ] he's
like some sage
[ __ ] silicon valley like foresight
clairvoyant guy and i'm like at 24 i
didn't know my ass from my elbow
and we are trying to expedite this but i
wonder how much of that
is just repackaging people getting older
you know like how when a
medicine is released and they need to
control for how much better
someone's recovery would have been
simply due to time
okay i feel like that's the equivalent
with some personal development i'm like
yeah
this is great but like after three or
four years i would have hoped i would
have stumbled up
upon some of this stuff in any case you
know what i mean trying to separate the
two
of how much you can expedite and how
much is just a byproduct of existing for
a bit longer
yeah and the way that i look at it is
that unfortunately some people will
never
experience it but i think it alway it
always comes at the right time and at
the right time at the beginning feels
like the wrong time
because any any massive change in my
life has come from immense amount of
pain
um and i think it's very hard to find
that young age
wisdom unless you've been through a lot
of pain and it's
and i think some of the you know some of
the younger generation i've spoken to
they've been through a lot of pain
they've been through a lot of things in
their life you know
like the reason that i got kind of
experienced and why it's quick as i
joined the join the army
you know i remember getting on a train
at 17 throwing up and crying
because i was just about to change my
life and be away from my family for the
first time in 17 years
um but that i grew up with
you know having to be more independent
and then my first operational tour in
baghdad yeah hugging
my dad and and saying i might not be
back
because you don't know what's going to
happen and it's all these things that
you process at the age of like
you know very early 20s that enable you
to
have perspective on other things that
happen in life
um but then you'd look at someone like
my brother who's
would would have be you know hasn't done
all of that experience
doesn't have that kind of level of
knowledge and it's fascinating because
you
you know you look and go that you know
not disrespectful but that could have
been me
like you know this could have been my
mindset with things
had i not just shut this [ __ ] mouth
and open these ears
um but i think as well a lot of
i think one of the talents of younger
people
which is a superpower if you can find
someone is just the ability to
not be distracted and to listen and i
think a lot of people
a lot of people listen to respond not
listen to understand
and that's what podca i think the
biggest change for me was when i
discovered this podcast button on my
iphone in 2011
because it was the first time i shut the
[ __ ] up and listened
and it had a a huge impact on my mindset
by listening to people who knew
a hell of a lot more about life than i
did um and i think that was the pinnacle
change for me
sort of nine i said nine yeah nine years
ago
and look at you now man killing it in
the podcast game creating content
helping other people
helping other people to do it as well
yeah
and uh i think because i realized the
power of just
shutting up and listening to people um
and i wish i
knew i wish i knew that at school that's
you know i think that's a byproduct of
the curiosity as well man
i really do um the
genuine hunger the desire to find out
what why or what or how or who
like that actual genuine desire is
so unique and so powerful and it sounds
it's like the pithiest
[ __ ] most like wanky quote in the
world to say something like that
but it genuinely genuinely is and it
goes back to like
your mum and dad saying well you've got
two ears and one mouth for a reason
and you're like oh god parents were
always right like
in one way or another weren't they yeah
exactly and
it's i think a lot of things all gear
back to a very few amount of
fundamentals and it's just
as of anything you know what you
understand when it comes to
fitness and fat loss it just comes down
to eating less than you burn if you want
to lose weight but just understand that
there's many different
ways of being able to achieve that and i
think you know when you
discover what the fundamental of
happiness is
then there's many different ways to
achieve it um but there's so many people
saying oh this that and the other and it
all comes from finding
people that you listen to and and you
know understand
quotes you know people say oh it's so
cliche this and that i'm like yeah but
it's
if it works for you then then do it um
and everyone you know i live my life
through analogies and quotes that's how
my brain functions through parables and
stories
because any part of my life that i'm
struggling with i'll have
found a parable to answer it um and
that's why i love books like chicken
soup for the soul
by jack canfield um and
and a lot of other um very much
the old ones that you hear at school you
know aesop's fables
some of those are probably the key
fundamentals of life especially the the
tortoise and the hair
you know that just solidifies james
clare's atomic habits but
ace up aesop was james clear before
james clear was james clay
couldn't agree more man like we we're
symbolic beings right uh jordan peterson
when i went to go see him live he said
why does thomas the tank engine need a
face like he's attacked he's a tank
engine
why do you need to personify this tank
engine it's because we
we personify everything in life you know
you give your car
like a personnel oh she's a bit this
today she's got these little quirks it's
like it
is it is by its very nature an inanimate
machine
and people people put [ __ ] eyelashes
on cars
have you done that and no i like it's
one of my
trigger points do you feel very strongly
about this
i feel incredibly strongly about putting
eyelashes on cars is one
that and android phones are my
non-negotiable we
are you are friends here you are
you are among friends here uh dude this
been awesome thank you
so much for your time what do you where
should people go they want to they want
to find out more about you or they want
to check out your products
where do you want to plug i would i
would say the best place to go just
um head on over to instagram at j
alderton i post
most of my stuff there i'll get back to
most of my messages so um
you know if you are listening to this
and something resonated with you
i'd love to hear what it was unreal man
thank you so much for your time
everything we've gone through will be
linked in the show notes below i'll try
and find the
article that i was talking about to do
in the vowel ravicans jealousy and
obviously
jay's fantastic insta will be linked
there as well for now man thank you
chris thank you
you